what is it that being in a committed  relationship did for you that you didn't  realize it might do beforehand there's a  different kind of freedom  in commitment i felt like i had a  program running in the background and  this program in the background was  constantly thinking  and worrying about which women were  single which ones were interested in me  and it was kind of just eating up a lot  of ram in my brain  and as soon as i hit that point it was  actually  almost instantaneous when i proposed my  wife it's like that program just shut  down and suddenly my computer  like my brain had like 30 more energy to  focus on other things  the feeling was of liberation